you're watching book TV next Rachel
Maddow talks about the US embrace of
perpetual war as a way of life and looks
at how our views of war and the business
of war has changed since Vietnam this is
about an hour and fifteen minutes good
evening everyone I am Lynn Pascarella
I'm president of Mount Holyoke College
it is my honor to welcome you to our
campus for what I know will be an
engaging evening Rachel Maddow is known
to all of us as the host of the Rachel
Maddow Show the critically acclaimed
MSNBC program where rachel takes on
issues at the forefront of public
discussion and private debate every day
she is an author a scholar and one of
the finest examples I know of Matt
Hollyoaks mission of using liberal
learning for purposeful engagement in
the world
Mount Holyoke has been educating women
for a hundred and seventy-five years and
I am so so proud to have such an
extraordinary role model on our campuses
evening before we get to Rachel's
presentation I want to introduce my dear
friend Joan Grenier from The Odyssey
bookshop without whom this event would
not be possible so Joan
hello everyone what a great night first
of all I want to say happy birthday says
our Chavez it would be 85 years old he
would be 85 years old today and he was
very important in my political
development The Odyssey bookshop is
honored to be co-sponsoring this event
with Montoya College the five College
women's studies Research Center and the
gender studies department this year okay
this fall the Odyssey bookshop will be
celebrating our 49th anniversary and
since you're such a captive audience I
have to tell you about some of our
programs our first edition Club has over
255 members around the country and
several international members we have an
incredible selection committee at the
Odyssey they have an amazing record of
choosing books that go on to win major
prizes including the recent selections
tiger Tigers wife by taya oberek which
won the Orange Prize in Open City by
Daisy Cole which won the Hemingway pen
award so once a month you would get a
signed first edition it's a great
graduation present it's a great Mother's
Day present it's like just a great
year-round present we also have a gift
of reading program and this is fantastic
for grandparents or aunts and uncles and
John and I are grandparents of three
girls now our children's book buyer will
hand pick a book each month for your
child there are four different age
groups spanning ages 2 to 18 the books
are gift wrap and it's just it's just so
much fun I want you all to visit our
website we just have a new website and
now you can purchase ebooks from us at
Odyssey bks calm for any device except a
Kindle Amazon is proprietary about that
so your iPads or tablets your iPhones
your Android smartphones your nooks your
soda readers your laptops your desktop
computers it's all you can do it very
easily so now we are a full-service
bricks and clicks book store I kind of
like that too
new books sale books ebooks and all and
over the next few months we will be
greatly expanding our use book
department lots of options for you to
support your locally owned independent
bookshop we host over 120
we host over 125 events a year and I
want to tell you about a couple Carole
de Santi will be with us on Thursday
April 5th at 7 p.m.
she's a Viking penguin editor known for
championing championing independent
original women's writing and her new
book is the unruly passion of Eugene R I
didn't say that it's it's French so I
can't do that - well the book is set in
bordellos Salim salons and streets of
nineteenth-century Paris a different
time from what Rachel will be talking
about tonight a different war but
surprisingly resonant with the issues
swirling around us today especially with
regard to women and then we are
delighted to be co-sponsoring that event
with the five College women's studies
Research Center and an incredible
reception will follow that at the center
with deserts to die for on April 10th we
are hosting the launch for Mount Holyoke
professor Dena faculty and author
Christopher BEM fee Chris will discuss
its critically acclaimed new memoir red
brick Black Mountain white play
reflections on art family and survival
and that event is co-sponsored with the
English department at mount ho
quickly quickly on April 19th Vijay
Prashad will be with us for his new book
Arab Spring Libyan winter and on the
24th Michael Clare from Hampshire
College the race for what's left the
global scramble for the world's last
resource resources and finally on
Wednesday April 25th National Priorities
project which is an organization that we
love dearly it's its national
headquarters is in Northampton
Massachusetts they're printing their
first book a people's guide to the
federal budget and that will be at 7
o'clock and we share a wonderful yes
we share a wonderful staffer with with
National Priorities project and that's
Sheila who does a lot of the social
media for both organizations and finally
I do want to mention that Sarita Gupta
Mount Holyoke class of 96 an executive
director of jobs with justice is
speaking upstairs in New York room on
April 18th at 4:15 so um I have quite a
fondness for the jobs of justice there's
a wonderful local organizer called named
John Weissman ok I'm married to a little
bit about the signing procedures there's
over 400 people who will be in line and
there's a dance in here at 11 o'clock so
no inscriptions no coast photoz will be
calling you up by the signing groups
ABCD and moving it right along so this
is Rachel's second event of the day and
she's in Cambridge tomorrow so we want
to keep the line going I really would
like you to join me in giving the
odyssey staff a warm round of applause
they have been incredible
and now it is my pleasure to introduce
another amazing woman
Karen Rimmer professor German studies
critical social thought and Gender
Studies at Mount Holyoke College and
director of the five College women's
studies Research Center Karen has worked
tirelessly to bring us all together
today to hear Rachel Maddow Karen
good evening I also wanted to give
generous thanks to Joan is through her
dedication to this community to South
Hadley to the Mount Holyoke community
that we have celebrated authors who come
here every week Thank You Joan and thank
your staff
many people work very hard to make this
event happen and I'd like to take just a
minute to thank some people by name and
many of you know that we appreciate your
work I'd like to thank Elizabeth Lehmann
who's the assistant director of the five
College women's studies Research Centre
Bridget Barrett for the senior
administrative assistant at gender
studies Mount Holyoke College Chris Berg
bum who is working up there thank you
all of these people and many more have
coordinated people space technology to
to make it possible for you all to sit
here comfortably in anticipation of
Rachel Maddow I'd also like to thank the
staff of facilities management and the
campus police for keeping the peace and
for setting up thank you so much okay
and then finally a heartfelt thanks to
president lynn pasquerella she's very
modest
she's also a frequent commentator on
radio as you know so she's out there for
us thank you I have the privilege of
directing the five college women studies
research center also celebrating an
anniversary 21 years we are an
international interdisciplinary center
that supports the work of feminist
scholars activists artists and
practitioners from around the world and
here in the Pioneer Valley in fact as
you know the Pioneer Valley and the five
colleges are probably the largest
concentration of feminists in the world
and I invite you I'm not going to go
through the whole list of events but we
have a table out in the lobby and I
invite you to pick up a flyer about some
of our upcoming events in the next
couple of weeks and we are always open
to the community so I welcome all of you
to join us we are especially pleased to
welcome Rachel Maddow this evening the
center is planning to launch a new
initiative on women the media and the
public sphere worldwide and we are
hoping to bring Rachel Maddow back at
some point along with other women who
have worked tirelessly rigorously around
the world to bring the news to you and
to comment about the politics of the day
and we hope many of you will jump into
the fray and also become commentators in
the public sphere real virtual local
global okay
I have to say one word of organization I
know you're all waiting Rachel Maddow
has generously agreed to answer
questions and again she's been working
tirelessly this week she's been on David
Letterman on Terry Gross on Jon Stewart
so she's very very busy so we have set
it up to have four mics we have two mics
we'll have two mics in either's aisle
one way up atop where all our students
are sitting
and then one on the second balcony and I
will not have moderate the
question-and-answer and we will take
turns will go one mic to the other so be
prepared to line up after Rachel speaks
Rachel Maddow is no stranger here
in fact she's a lot of your neighbor a
lot of you have her as her neighbor she
also started her first radio gig down
the road in Holyoke Massachusetts as
many of you know and as President
Pascarella mentioned she is a brilliant
scholar she has a degree from Stanford
University Oxford University she's a
Rhodes Scholar and an Emmy award-winning
television host of her own show I have
read her book drift the unmooring of
American military power and I recommend
it to you I've been recommending it to
everyone including the Marines that I
know I think though they actually
confirm a lot of what's in the book so
far she argues that the military the US
military has become so private that many
Americans stay out of the whole process
of going to war altogether she reminds
us of unexpected connections say between
the cost of daycare for toddlers of
military parents and a bird called the
who borrow bus start hunted in
Balochistan Pakistan she reminds us that
this book took a lot of time a lot of
intensive research much of which was
available in the public record so listen
to what your elected officials have to
say read the documents and also follow
the money
Rachel herself on her blog said recently
the book is not about Democrats and
Republicans it's not about liberals and
conservatives and not even about good
and bad guys it is about America as a
great country that has forgotten one of
the things that makes us great and I
think we can get back to what that was
and I would love it if we could at least
have a big national talk about it
so Rachel Maddow is here to have to
continue that big national and I would
say international talk about
it so welcome please Rachel Maddow
you're embarrassing me thank you I have
four hours and 45 minutes left of being
38 Oh
[Applause]
thank you very much like this wasn't
embarrassing enough already
I have never written a book before and I
don't think I'm ever going to write a
book again and but the the what that
means for tonight is that I don't know
how to do this I don't know who knows
how to do this right
is there a normal thing to do I don't
know what I'm planning on doing is
reading a short thing actually that
Karen was just talking about about the
who borrow bustard and then just briefly
telling you a little bit about what the
book is about and then I will happily
take your questions and at the end of
the night I will sign books are there
any objections
hearing none and I will say two things
as a matter of preface one is that it's
really nice that you guys have come out
to see me you may know me from TV I'm
guessing most of you do but whether or
not you know me from TV you know enough
about this book to know that it's about
the military and about Paulette the
politics of war making in this country
and that is not your standard like
Saturday night let's go hang out kind of
thing I realize this is not candy you
know this isn't like hey I met some jerk
who disagrees with me and let me tell
you how jerky he is that can be more fun
sometimes and so this just the fact that
you're here and you would consider
reading it and you're here to hear me
talk about it is very heartening to me
because you hear all over and over again
that all anybody wants is the easy stuff
and this is not the easy stuff so thank
you for being here the other thing I
would say is before you leave you should
probably meet somebody here who you
don't already know because if you all
like me and you want to come out on a
Saturday night and talk about the
military you probably like each other so
if there are people here who you don't
know I don't mean to like set you up on
dates or whatever but
I'm just saying this is probably a good
place to make new friends so we'll do
like a peace be with you thing at the
end of the Hamline
all right the Jabara bustard is not a
particularly large or regal bird it
looks a little like what you might get
if you bred a common thent with an
ostrich like like a miniature ostrich
with a shorter neck and legs or maybe
it's like a pheasant on steroids with a
stretched neck and sprinters legs and a
much more impressive wingspan but the
little fella the who borrowed bustard
has recently provided crucial assistance
in making America's war in Afghanistan
and it's spillover in Pakistan the
longest-running military hot show in our
nation's history
in May 2011 Pakistan got its nose out of
joint when US special forces sprung a
surprise mission on a compound in
Abbottabad and off the most infamous
terrorists on the planet without giving
a heads up to the host government the
Pakistani military and intelligence
service found itself having to explain
how the target Osama bin Laden could
have been living in tranquility just a
few miles down the road from Pakistan's
most important military academy in a
neighborhood crawling with current and
retired military officers was Pakistani
intelligence that incompetent or were
they protecting bin Laden and then they
had to explain how a u.s. strike force
and its very large helicopters could fly
into a bot Avadh spend nearly an hour on
the ground and then leave the country
with bin Laden's carcass in tow without
being detected let alone stopped while
President Obama and the rest of America
took a celebratory victory lap the
Pakistanis found the entire episode
hugely shaming but not so much on the
bin Laden in our backyard count they
really focused on the lack of respect
accorded their own nation by the United
States quote American troops coming
across the border and taking action in
one of our towns is not acceptable to
the people of Pakistan said former
President Pervez Musharraf the day after
the raid it is a violation of our
sovereignty the Pakistani Parliament
called the country's military and
intelligence chieftains into a rare and
Mara
on closed-door session where the
generals did have a spot of trouble in
covering their respective lapses but
they did definitely deflect much of the
civilians ire the United States they
reminded everyone was the real bad guy
here the generals had little trouble
encouraging Parliament to formally
demand that henceforth the United States
would ensure that Pakistan's national
interests were fully respected ally
Sh'ma lie the Pakistani people deserve
some respect to add some bite to this
declaration of sovereignty
the generals suggested a good first step
would be forcing the u.s. to shut down
the secret program the CIA had been
running out of an airbase in a remote
corner of Pakistan called Baluchistan
unfortunately in publicizing their
demand that the CIA leave that airbase
the generals also revealed to surprised
Pakistani legislators that the CIA had
been using that airbase this was cause
for an uproar in Parliament but the fact
that the CIA had been flying armed
drones out of the airfield known as
Shamsi came as much less of a surprise
to the citizens of the areas those
drones were targeting the tribal regions
the CIA's rather dump be looking a
high-tech unmanned aircraft had been
used mainly for surveillance in the
early stages of the war in Afghanistan
but they could also be armed with
Hellfire missiles very occasionally from
2004 to 2007 and more frequently in 2008
the George W Bush administration had
used drones to launch airborne attacks
on suspected terrorists in Pakistan when
the Obama administration took over in
2009 the number of drone attacks spiked
the next year the 2009 numbers more than
doubled the Obama administration refused
as a matter of policy to officially
acknowledge the CIA's drone attacks but
in the days following a big get they
announced that some key al-qaida or
Haqqani network leader was killed as if
the event were an act of Providence or
like a rainbow a remarkable atmospheric
happening these drone attacks had become
the centerpiece of Obama's recalibration
of America's global war on terror even
if we didn't call it that anymore
the Obama administration had no
intention of pulling up stakes in Shamsi
quote that base is neither vacated nor
being vacated was the anonymous but
official word from Washington it was a
Mexican standoff in Baluchistan here's
rather who Barra bustard provided a
little wiggle room in what was otherwise
sort of a naughty situation naughty with
a K not naughty with a G you forget
about you know you forget about homonyms
when you're reading out loud that's
weird
anyway this tiny forgotten strip of land
that held the airbase in sham sea it
turned out it did not actually belong to
Pakistan it had been quietly signed over
to the United Arab Emirates 20 years
earlier in a shot in a sign of
friendship between the two countries you
see Baluchistan aside from being full of
spectacular garden of eden' natural
wonders and it is supposed to be among
the most beautiful places on earth aside
from that though Baluchistan is among
the few wintering grounds of the who
bara bustard and the who bara bustard is
a bird held in high esteem among hunters
from the United Arab Emirates and Saudi
Arabia and Qatar falconry is of course
the sport of Arab kings and the poor
bustard had long been the preferred prey
for falconers so Emirati royalty were
frankly really pleased to have this
special foothold in Baluchistan and
right away they built themselves a
sizable landing strip so they could get
easy access to the surprisingly
sought-after
remote corner of the world quote the
sheiks tell me it is the ultimate
challenge for the Falcon a chieftain and
baluchistan told the writer for The New
Yorker named Mary Ann Weaver back around
the time that the Emiratis built that
Shaughnessy airstrip quote the Falcon is
the fastest bird on earth and the who
bara bustard is also fast both on the
ground and in the air it also is a
clever weary bird with a number of
tricks
among these tricks this is my single
favorite part of the book
it's really gross among these tricks the
chieftain continued is an ability to
inkjet a dirt green slime violently from
its vent
you know what the vent is on a bird
right to inkjet a dark green slime
violently from its vent its force is so
strong that it can spread four three
feet and it can temporarily blind the
Falcon or glue the Falcons feathers
together making it unable to fly
you now don't have to buy the book
because that's the best thing in it the
belief also persisted that the meat of
the Jabara bustard was an aphrodisiac
not hard to see why the bustard had been
sought and consumed with such sustained
effort that the bird was nearly extinct
on the Arabian Peninsula cold war
politics had added degrees of difficulty
for the sportsmen as well the fall of
the Shah in 1979 made bustard hunting
problematic for Sunni Arabs in Shiite
Iran has had the near constant state of
war in Afghanistan so baluchistan
emerged as the destination spot for
latter-day Arab Nimrods for the last
twenty years or so
emirati sheiks and Saudi princes and the
more general run of ambitious Arab
dignitaries had jockey for the best
allotments in the last good place on
earth to hunt this poor bustard when
Pakistan's Foreign Office be stowed upon
the Emiratis an allotment that was once
held by the Saudis the Saudis withheld
oil supplies from Pakistan and money for
flood relief in retaliation Arab royalty
of various stripes show up every year
with according to Weaver's description
pop up tent cities hundreds of servants
satellite dishes for better
communication and hunting vehicles
tricked out with sophisticated laptops
infrared spotlights and bustard seeking
radar maybe not sporting but certainly
effective I'm almost done the Emiratis
had made one concession that did
slightly crimp their style in the
bustard hunting department in the weeks
after the 9/11 attacks in 2001 when
everybody wanted to pitch in they had
agreed with the consent of Pakistani
President Musharraf to let the Americans
use Shamsi as a base to supply US troops
fighting the Taliban just across the
border in Afghanistan and also maybe for
a few special and classified operations
in the ten years that followed as the
CIA and its many private contractors
began operating lethal attack drones out
of sham see the remote top secret base
remained off-limits to Pakistan's own
Air Force so when the bleep hit the fan
when the slime hit the Falcon
in the aftermath of the bin Laden raid
thanks to the who bara bustard everybody
had an out the United States could make
it plain that the CIA was not vacating
Shamsi and Pakistan could still save
face Pakistani government officials
could say and they did hey we just
checked our land records and it turns
out this little strip of Baluchistan is
not legally speaking Pakistan controlled
territory after all we gave it to the
Emiratis for bustard hunting so sorry
but there's nothing we can do to stop
this part of America's secret drone war
operating out of Shamsi but we do
condemn it in the strongest possible
language the United Arab Emirates
meanwhile went on record saying they had
only built the airstrip emirati sheiks
and others used it for they said
recreational purposes what recreation
the CIA was pursuing there the Emiratis
couldn't say Shamsi they assured the
world was never operated or controlled
by the United Arab Emirates and so we
still had our drone base in Shamsi and
no skittish ally had to take the blame
for having hand it over handed it over
to us
so that's a little bit of how the book
goes that is the best part it just not
the whole section but like that part
about the slime I think is the best I am
NOT an expert on the military I am NOT
an expert on war my gig is politics and
that's what I have pursued as an
activist and what I studied as an
academic and what I bloviate about on
television and this book is a book about
politics it is about the politics of
going to war and the politics of not
going to war and the politics of ending
wars that we are in the consternation
over the Vietnam War led to a
multi-front effort to make sure that we
did not end up in a mess like that again
the Congress passed a War Powers Act
which reasserted that presidents can't
just take us into big Wars on their own
say-so Congress having sole
constitutional authority to declare war
means that they've got to not just be
told but be asked about war Congress is
the body that gets to decide Congress
aside from the War Powers Act also after
Vietnam got up on its hind legs as they
say actually as only I say
and exerted simply a more muscular
attitude toward matters of national
security
Gerald Ford wanted to essentially
re-engage with Vietnam after we had left
in a way that many members of Congress
believed would get us started into that
war again and Congress stopped him from
doing it he was set on doing it he
thought it was the right thing to do for
the country and Congress members of
Congress Democrat and Republicans said
no and when he and the Congress had a
very very serious confrontation over it
one that horrified Gerald Ford he
thought that Congress was way
overstepping his bounds they went so far
as to tell him that they would use the
appropriations process they would
withhold dollars to stop him from doing
what he wanted to do the powers of the
presidency I think were confronted even
if they weren't changed by that newly
muscular attitude from Congress but it
is a balance and that was a time when
Congress flexed its muscles but maybe I
think the most interesting change that
Vietnam brought us that doesn't get as
much attention in civilian life because
we don't feel like it's our business
really was the Abrams Doctrine Creighton
Abrams was head of the army as the
Vietnam War was winding down and he died
very shortly after the end of the war
but before he died he worked on
something called the total force policy
which usually gets short-handed as the
aprons doctrine and the idea was that
the military would be restructured so we
couldn't go to war in big ways without
disrupting civilian life specifically
without calling up the garden reserves
when LBJ was trying to make a decision
about escalating in Vietnam he knew that
he didn't want to make the argument to
the country about why that was smart to
do he had been making the argument as a
politician for years that it was not
smart to escalate in Vietnam LBJ would
talk about not wanting to send American
boys thousands of miles around the world
to do what Asian boys ought to be doing
for themselves he was not in favor of it
he didn't want to make the political
argument for it and yet he felt like he
had to do it so LBJ's solution was oh
we'll expand to the draft nobody will
notice that
we had had a draft constantly at that
point in our in our country for decades
um bless you but the what he what he
avoided what he didn't do
because he didn't want upset the country
too much is that he didn't call up the
garden reserves
he thought there's all these people who
are pretty well connected who have
well-connected parents at least who are
in the garden reserves and I don't want
to go calling up the garden reserves if
I'm gonna have to hear from all these
well-connected constituents about this
war that I don't really want to defend
so we'll do the draft that'll keep it
quiet
and not very many compared to modern
conflicts certainly not very many
Guardsmen and reservists ended up
serving on the ground in Vietnam the
draft was used to expand the people
explain the number of people we have
there instead but when Abrams got a hold
of this idea of restructuring the
military he said you know what garden
reserves are gonna have to do we are
going to operationally structure the
army so that you can't have a big
military operation of any kind without
having Guardsmen and reservists there
and why so that civilian life would be
disrupted by the fact that we were in
war and that there would not be a divide
between civilian life and military life
that had so crippled the country I think
emotionally and politically and
cathartic ly at the end of at the end of
Vietnam and I think that was important
to the politics of war it would keep the
country focused on and feeling the
sacrifice that war entailed it wouldn't
be the military awful known doing its
own thing Ronald Reagan's presidency
changed a lot of that he started a war
in Grenada with Congress barely knowing
about it when Congress said no to what
he wanted to do in Central America he
secretly went around them to do it
anyway just flagrantly breaking the law
when he got caught and his
administration was trying to save his
presidency they invented a brand-new
radically expanded doctrine of
presidential power that essentially said
that a president alone as one person can
direct any war related action anywhere
on earth even in direct contradiction of
a law passed by Congress which is
bizarre
and that bizarre idea which I really do
think was simply cooked up on the spot
to save Reagan's but at the end of
iran-contra that became the basis of the
political life of a obscure Wyoming
congressman named Dick Cheney
and that became unexpectedly important
years later when Congress's previous
muscularity on issues of war and not war
actually went all flabby and then Dick
Cheney as White House chief of staff and
then later as defense secretary he came
up with something that was essentially
the cure to the Abrams doctrine instead
of making sure that the manpower needs
of the military engaged the whole
country whenever we went to war he
restructured the thing so that the
manpower needs of the military would be
met as quietly as possible with as
little civilian upset as possible it
would those manpower needs would be met
in part for profit privately the
clinton-gore administration was
delighted to embrace and expand on that
Cheney project it made it much easier
for them for example when they needed to
get around their own political
constraints to use force in the Balkans
and so this book is not about the merits
of any individual war the Congress waxes
and wanes and its interest in
constraining and overseeing and
directing matters of war even though the
Constitution does put them in charge of
it the president's new expanded powers
that treat the US military essentially
as one man's personal army those powers
have grown ingrown the military itself
has become more and more hived off
cleaved from civilian life the national
security budget keeps growing and
becoming more and more impenetrable more
and more gets declared secret the
politics get more and more muted the
wars get longer and longer in our sense
that something is wrong
gets deeper i I feel both for the guy
who's putting the magnetic yellow ribbon
on the back of his SUV and the person
you know in the bike lane next to them
cursing that dumb magnetic yellow ribbon
on the back of your SUV that's
self-defeating and impotent I feel for
both of those things because I actually
think they come from the same place they
come from a sense that we are a country
that has not gone to war we sent a
military to war and they went without us
and I think that people feel that on the
left and on the right and I think people
feel that who have no politics at all
we barely noticed when the Iraq war
ended after eight and a half years more
than 4,000 Americans killed even if you
only care about the Americans killed and
not the Iraqis killed after all of that
time when it ended when did it end
December it was a ho-hum shrug from the
civilian population I mean st. Louis
threw a parade but New York didn't these
are changes that I think have happened
over a relatively short period of time I
do not think there was a conspiracy here
although I love hearing conspiracy
theories because I find them very
entertaining I think essentially we had
a series of understandable decisions
made by people looking at short term
political necessity I see something that
I think we ought to do for national
security purposes but the price tag is
going to sound way too high for people
let's tell them it's free let's give
them a tax cut tell them it's free and
hope that they don't notice when their
grandkids have to pay for it I want to
deploy a large number of Americans but I
don't really want to have to answer for
how many Americans I am deploying let's
have some of them be working for private
companies because then we not only do we
not have to answer for how much we're
paying them we don't have to answer for
what the lines of accountability are
when they do something wrong and if they
die or get hurt and nobody will ever
know I think I want to do something for
national security but the Congress has
passed a law against it I'm going to
assert that I am above that law I'd like
to wage a war in I don't know say
Pakistan
but I don't want to get around the
political constraints that are between
me and a war in Pakistan so I will wage
one in secret and not answer when asked
about it I don't think all of those
decisions happened all at once
I think they happen over a relatively
short period of time though and I think
it was all about trying to get around
these annoying constraints keeping us
from waging Wars we wanted to wage and
and and keeping us from from using the
military in ways that we wanted to use
it and those annoying constraint
are some of the best things we inherited
from the founding fathers those annoying
constraints are there for a reason the
Constitution is structured to put 535
squabbling members of Congress in charge
of whether or not to declare war because
a squabble among 535 members of Congress
about something that important is due to
be loud and take a long time and be a
pain and it will engage us all and that
was the point if they wanted it to be
easy to go to war they would have given
more making power to the President and
they emphatically did not and they
talked about it at the time and we can
read their letters about it so again
this is this is not about the merits of
any one war I think we have cut away
from the mooring that we got from our
Constitution to make us not too warlike
as a country not to make us a pacifist
country and I'm not a pacifist and I
know that I have a lot of respect for
pacifism as a way of life in a way of
thinking about these things it's not my
point of view I believe that sometimes
wars are necessary I want us to have an
excellent military but I do believe that
the Constitution structured us to be a
deliberately peaceable nation where
peacetime is our default and Wars the
operation and that's been flipped
and it turns out there's this bustard
that slimes falcons and makes their
feathers stick together so they crash
and it turns out that if you leave
nuclear weapons sitting around for too
long they grow fungus so they're you
know there's I really enjoyed writing
this I hate writing but I liked writing
this and it came out the way I meant it
to and I'm grateful that you are here
and would consider reading it because
I'd love for us to have a big national
fight about this stuff I think it can
all be fixed thank you very much for
being here
no no you can stand there thank you so
much
okay yeah we didn't rehearse this so
we're not sure where we're standing but
we both have my advance okay yeah
okay we have time for a few questions
and as I said previously we're going to
start up in the balcony and I already
see someone standing ready to go go
ahead and ask your so I actually have a
question about the parade for the vets
that was in st. Louis
I was wondering both if you've seen any
movement towards having a New York
parade and if you think there's any just
any legitimate justification for not
having that parade until all the vets
come home excellent question
I totally think that there are two
legitimate sides to the debate I don't
think that I am inclined to think that
we ought to we ought to do it that we
ought to mark the end of the Iraq war in
a way that would let civilians say thank
you to veterans welcome them home and to
acknowledge that this thing that they
did has been concluded the Pentagon's
line on it is understandable and they're
lying on it is listen you know the Iraq
and Afghanistan wars are separate
political entities but the same people
have been fighting both of these wars
and we've got 90,000 Americans deployed
right now in Afghanistan and so to
welcome them home from Iraq is
essentially welcoming home them home
from a political entity when a lot of
them are not physically actually home
and I absolutely I have a lot of respect
for that viewpoint and I a lot of people
who I know who care about this issue as
much as I do
adopt that as their position I've just
talked to a lot of Iraq and Afghanistan
veterans who say you know what I've been
in both places I've been deployed in
both places and if I were in Afghanistan
right now knowing that there's been a
parade at home to mark the end of the
Iraq war would make me psyched to be
able to come think about coming home to
do that for me when I'm home from
Afghanistan too so you know I don't
think this is a I don't think this is an
issue where you're wrong if you're on
once
you're right if you're on the other I
would love to debate it I think it's
weird that the Pentagon wants there to
be a it's a that's they support their
being parades in every other country
every other city in the country but not
in New York
the Christine Quinn who's the head of
the City Council in New York and a few
the city councilors there still want to
do it
Iraq and Afghanistan Veterans of America
support the idea the Pentagon is
advising against it but they don't
probably get the last word on this so I
think it's still sort of an open
question thank you we have a question in
the second balcony this is this one yes
Rachel I've read and really enjoyed your
book but one of the premises of your
book is the demise of the citizen
soldier after Vietnam and you discuss
several reasons in Vietnam for that but
one you don't discuss is the fact that a
significant portion of those civilian
soldiers in Vietnam revolted mutiny
against their army killed their soldiers
killed their officers when they resisted
it and this scared the [ __ ] out of the
army and ever since that incident they
have eliminated the civilian soldier
they have turned themselves into a
professional Harmonie army so they never
have to face that kind of revolt again
could you comment on that and why it was
never mentioned in your book sure um I I
think that that is it's implicit when
you talk to the military right now about
this I think left and right fulmination
among civilians that we ought to bring
back the draft a lot of people say a lot
of people have said to me about the book
since it's come out but I think people
whenever they talk about this issue
broadly talk about how we need to bring
back the draft so that people are more
connected to civilians are more
connected to the threat of military
service so everybody has some skin in
the game and the reason that usually
gets shut down doesn't go much further
than that is because the military says
absolutely not the military is
absolutely no interest in there being a
draft they don't want to be in an
environment whether it's a training
environment or a combat environment with
people who don't want to be there now
you're right the last time that was true
was in Vietnam and
ultimately I think that the civilian
soldier idea is broader than just the
draft is broader than just conscription
it is the idea that we are not a country
that maintains a massive standing
military force that we are looking to
use all the time I think that's a that's
something that the founding fathers
debated and we sort of decided something
different than what we ended up with the
citizen-soldier idea is that we have a
peaceable economy and a peaceable
country that is dislocated temporarily
for the purpose of going to war and then
we go back to normalcy that hasn't been
true for a very very long time but it's
a very good question okay down here
please we have the question dealers down
here so I will confess I am a big nerd I
had your book overnighted to me and
actually read it in advance of tonight
thank you you agree that the bustard
part was the best part thirty miles from
the fungus riddled wings of Barksdale
Air Force Base
so that struck home as well but anyway
what struck me is interesting most
interesting about the book was you talk
a lot about the executive branch you
talk a lot about the exec the
legislative branch and there's not a lot
about the judiciary and we've over the
past week
you know witness the role of the
judiciary in determining what is and
what is not constitutional and one of
the premises of the book is that the
executive has overstepped his
constitutional authority to declare war
and I'm wondering why you don't think
that there's been any role of the
judiciary in this to check that power
it's a totally totally good question and
it is because the judiciary has deferred
to Congress because the judiciary looks
at the division of powers in the
Constitution and says yeah we know this
isn't us and we know it's not you it's
you guys you guys are supposed to use
your equal power as a Congress to weigh
in here and take that power back and you
know you see that and one one point in
the book there's this forgotten to
history now and it's weird cuz it's not
that long ago but members of Congress
sued in court in federal court to stop
George HW Bush from waging Gulf War one
this was my Lancet is of the trial and
to disobey exactly which is all about
Joe it's called
mylanta tis because it's about George HW
Bush feeling the weight of the world on
his shoulders for having to make this
decision about war as one man and you
just want to scream into the book dude
it's not supposed to be you alone some
members of Congress were yelling that at
him and actually decided to seek federal
a federal court injunction to stop the
war which is a crazy idea and the ruling
from the judge in the case is a
beautiful thing it is really beautifully
articulated I could have essentially
just plagiarized it and made that the
thesis statement of the book but at the
end of it he says Ann's having concluded
that you are right and the president is
doing stuff he's not supposed to be
doing and these are Congress's powers
dude these are Congress's powers I as a
judge can't stop him from doing anything
you as Congress have the power to stop
him but it can't just be this dozen
members of Congress however many people
it was a small group suing to do it you
actually have to take action as Congress
which means you have to act by majority
vote within yourself as an institution
to stop the president from doing this
thing do your job and it's this it's a
bucket of cold water but it's that's
it's true that you know I don't expect
any president no matter you know I mean
you could reincarnate Jesus and elect
president Jesus and maybe that would
work but aside from president Jesus I
don't expect that any president would
give back power that the executive
branch had accrued through the precedent
of the actions of previous presidents
nobody gives away power if you're
president you think you've got the
country's best interest at heart and
you're stymied all the time by other
people in politics who don't want the
best things for the country you're not
going to give away power to get
something done if you believe that
you're doing what's right and other
people are stopping you
presidents don't give power away it's
like an aged rubber band that only
stretches one direction Congress has to
take that power back and Congress has to
do it on their own behalf and we don't
have much
in Congress to do anything right now to
do something that big maybe seems like
pie in the sky but that's what needs to
happen I think thank you so first of all
thank you for coming out tonight
my question has more to do with the
nature of the word that we're talking
about in your book you talk a lot about
more formal wars or formal declaration
of wars so my question is what does the
role of this sort of more stateless era
of war in counterterrorism have to do
with the military's functioning you know
whether that's a reclassification of
combatants is illegal or
reinterpretations of wartime powers what
does that have to do with how the
military is functioning that's different
from before excellent question and very
hard to answer I will tell you I think
that basically that I think that there
is reasonable wiggle room in terms of
the way that we are set up as a country
under the president's commander-in-chief
powers to do some things in an almost
unilateral or temporarily unilateral way
when speed is of the essence when I mean
that the way the founders talked about
it was to do things like repel invasion
there are some things where I think the
the president is given authority to act
as a military commander outside what we
think of as the constitutional
prerogatives of we're making limited
it's very limited powers and to the
extent that war making right now is
about transnational groups that don't
have governments that speak for them and
that don't have borders that they
respect I think that those two things
have worked together to radically expand
the amount of military power we use
without any different difference to
Congress whatsoever for example we do a
lot of military a lot of our military
work now through the CIA and the CIA is
a SEC essentially functioning as another
branch of the military but they are one
that has deniability deniability I guess
they think in terms of
one whether we explain or own up to
their actions and I can see why somebody
who wants the power to act in the
nation's national security interests
wants the flexibility to be act able to
act anywhere in the world in secret deny
they ever did it never explain it and
cover it up if necessary
I just don't think that's America I can
understand why somebody wants that power
but we are not designed to give anybody
that power at least in a sustained way
so it's I think it's put pressure on all
the weak points of where we were already
drifting anyway thank you thank you up
in the balcony top balcony good evening
thank you so much for being here with us
tonight my question is after the war in
Vietnam there was a very clear period of
reflection and questioning both on the
part of the American public in American
politicians as to what are the lessons
we learned from this war and my question
is do you think that a similar period of
reflection and questioning will come
about after in the aftermath of Iraq and
Afghanistan or are we too removed as a
nation from our military actions for
that to happen that is the big $64,000
question that I was when I was on The
Daily Show this week and that was Jon
Stewart's question he said I see that
all these things that you are implicitly
praising after Vietnam happened after
the National upheaval that was Vietnam
do we need something that big again in
order to assert for example Congress has
power over these things in order to make
the kinds of changes that you say and I
I think it's arguable I mean to have
thought not only the longest war in
American history but alongside that to
have fought another eight and a half
year long in Iraq concurrent with the
longest war in American history and to
have had only one percent of the
population fighting those wars and for
them to be completely unpaid for and for
the civilian population to be
continuously granting itself multi
trillion dollar tax cuts over the course
of those
when you put all those things together I
think you are approaching unsustainable
crisis just in terms of how we think of
ourselves as a country
I am a big believer in in protest
movements I think that direct action
gets the goods and I think that the
reason there were so many changes after
Vietnam is because people were in the
streets
I don't foresee that happening on this
issue now because we are in your to the
fact that these wars are happening in
our name because it feels like it's
something separate because we don't even
notice when Iraq ends I don't foresee
that kind of mass social movement but we
also have a situation in which there's
no partisan affiliation in terms of how
people feel about these things how
people feel about the Afghanistan war is
completely disassociated from people's
party position at this point so that's
pretty radical almost every
controversial issue in American politics
is bifurcated by party or at least by
liberal and liberal and conservative
ideological lines not this so no we
don't have a mass social movement
pushing for this but if anybody does
push on these issues I think they will
find that they are pushing on an open
door I don't think there is going to be
as much resistance to these things as we
think so to me it feels fixable I feel
like the crisis that we are in is big
enough the way that it is manifesting is
with a national disgust rather than with
a national protest movement it's gonna
remain to be seen I actually I do hope
that this book can be part of naming the
problem so we can talk about how to fix
it thank you thank you
okay middle balcony hi your show and the
information on your show the stories
that you tell and your book are so well
researched and I'm just kind of curious
how you ensure that the facts are facts
through long hours and cross-referencing
I mean they're you know we get stuff
wrong and one of the things that I find
weird about TV is that there is not a
there's not a history of on-air
Corrections for factual misstatements on
television which I don't understand I
got it's it's a it's a like cause or a
giant ripple of excitement whenever we
do a correction on the air but if we get
something wrong I try to correct it for
the record I called John Poindexter a
marine in the book he's a Navy admiral
I'm very sorry
I mean mistakes happen there aren't
there are things that get screwed up but
you have to I think it's like in your in
your academic work you have to do
everything you can
possibly do to make sure you know what
you are talking about before you say
anything at all read first talk later
you have to have somebody with fresh
eyes checking your work and then
somebody checking their work and you
have to be willing to be wrong you have
to be willing to make it right when you
are caught out for something that's
wrong especially if you catch it out
yourself and nobody else nails you for
it so it's it's a spectrum and a process
as they say there's no there's no magic
bullet you just have to work really hard
at it and care about it
thank you okay go ahead over here
congratulations on the Steinbeck award
oh thank you in your interview there you
are talking about how the Republicans
are willing to lose battles in order to
win the war
and you just said that this is sort of a
door to be pushed on do you think that
that's a good way for liberals to bring
the discussion back to the center and
perhaps move in a more progressive
fashion to open that door of
conversation and what do you think are
some steps that we can take to bring the
country back toward the left it's it's a
good question and I don't think I know
the answer to it I mean the basic
problem in left versus right politics is
that and you know this I can tell them
the premise of it's implicit in the
premise of your question but basically
my idea is that on the right you've got
the conservative movement which is well
funded well organized thinking
generationally knows exactly where it's
going and knows exactly how it's going
to get there and has almost infinite
resources to do it and then you've got
the Republican Party which is kind of
not that also just I mean
I don't I don't mean Republicans aren't
that awesome I mean like the Republican
Party is not a very good organization
they are not very good at what they do
they're not as good at what they do
actually as the Democratic Party is but
they're no I don't I don't I don't if
you are applauding because you're a
Democrat you like if you like the
compliment okay but what I don't I don't
mean Democrats good Republicans mad I
mean Democrats good at running a
political party Republicans bad at
running a political party it doesn't
they're not good at the basic stuff you
need to do in order to be organized but
they don't need to be because there's
the conservative movement and so they
just hook themselves onto the
conservative movement and they do what
they're told and if it sometimes means
they have to lose elections in the short
run because they are advocating against
contraception or something in 2012 the
conservative movement doesn't care about
the Republicans short-term electoral
interests because they've got their eyes
on generational change and so because of
that that's why that's why you get this
phenomenon on the right that you don't
get on the Left democratic politics have
essentially been the same for most of my
adult life the policy positions have not
changed except they've skidded a little
bit to the right but they certainly have
gotten more liberal and they haven't
moved very much Republican politics move
so fast so far to the right that they're
constantly turning on each other and
having to reinvent themselves I mean
John McCain and Sarah Palin ran on a
cap-and-trade bail out the bank's
platform
in 2008 Sarah Palin right I mean Mitt
Romney is has to run against not only
himself as a governor Mitt Romney has to
run against himself as the guy who ran
in 2008 they're constantly outpacing
themselves and that's because the
conservative movement is making them
whoever's got the farthest right
position in politics becomes the new
standard bearer and they all scoot over
and then who's ever further away from
them they all scoot over and so when you
do that meanwhile the Democrats are like
standing over here so but if these
Democrats are standing here a couple
kind of fighting amongst ourselves
interests crew how much do we care about
Union is it okay that the Senate
majority leader is anti I don't know I
just
that's Democrats and Republicans are
over here and they're like looking to
the right and as you do that Democrats
whenever they have to compete in general
election terms of the Republicans are
constantly scooching over here to try to
be sort of centrist seeming and that
means that the center moves to the right
which means that there are Republicans
who fall off that rightward edge all the
time but it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter to the conservative movement in
the long run they don't care about short
term election cycle politics in 2012
they're gonna lose all those Midwest
governorships that they won in 2010
because they got the guns those guys in
in 2010 then had them run like they were
running Alabama Wisconsin is not Alabama
they're gonna lose that and
that dynamic doesn't exist on the left
there's nobody who's pulling the
Democratic Party to the left so how do
progressives pull the Democratic party
to the left discuss okay
we're gonna do three more questions okay
yep go ahead thank you for the work that
you do logging those long hours to
increase the amount of useful
information that we have to work with
thank you in large part through what
I've learned from your show I've begun
to realize that we do have a shadow army
of private contractors who do who fight
you know in our name if not under our
banner per se and I'm wondering who has
the leverage to dial down those forces
when that becomes you know I think
before it becomes a point of crisis it's
this is one of these things that I think
is doable and you will hear in
Washington that it's completely undoable
remember back in the 2008 Democratic
primary both senator Clinton and Senator
Obama were very outspoken against the
use of contractors for what used to be
military purposes they both said that
they were going to dial those things way
back that there was no reason we needed
to use contractors for things that the
military used to do for themselves it
was not saving us money it was costing
us in terms of our accountability in the
world and it was causing all sorts of
problems they were doing all sorts of
bad things that then our soldiers had to
answer for in a way that wasn't safe
even just for our military they both
sort of said in my opinion all the right
things and now as Secretary of State
State Department is a huge number of
contractors and as president in charge
of everything the number the contractor
issue has not gotten any better so what
they say in Washington is that the
contractors are just too integral to
what we do we if we killed all the
contract but proverbially killed all the
contractors we got rid of all the
contracts in the short term we couldn't
do anything tomorrow and maybe it feels
that way I'm sure the contractors have
made themselves seem indispensable but
the reason I write about it a lot and in
some sort of disturbing detail about
what happened in the Balkans in the
is to remind everybody that it hasn't
been that long that we have had
Halliburton and DynCorp and all these
groups peeling potatoes it has not been
that long and we were fine as a military
power before we had that happen there's
always been some involvement of private
businesses and indeed profiteering in
war making but the outsourcing of
logistic logistics of being at war
things like laundry food building
barracks driving convoys VIP security
that kind of stuff that was a purely
military function really not that long
ago at all and so if it could be created
in 20 years it can be gotten rid of too
we can go back to the way it was and
where it came from is kind of a funny
story and I think it's chapter four but
thank you it could be done and it takes
will and actually there been some it's
one of those things where there's been
some interesting cross across the aisle
leadership on it Claire McCaskill is a
relatively conservative Democratic
senator she conserve it on something
she's progressive on others but one she
is she is if she gets reelected in
Missouri I expect her to be the one who
holds the banner highest for doing that
in defense Thanks okay on the balcony
[Applause]
good evening Rachel I've been I've been
watching your show since the 2008
electoral season so it's an honor to
finally see you speak in person thank
you my question relates to the u.s.
involvement in the recent crisis in
Libya where the u.s. working with NATO
and the Libyan rebels themselves was
able to successfully ask mark Qadhafi
from power without laying a single us
food on the ground so to speak do you
see this kind of involvement working
with intergovernmental organizations and
focusing on less manpower and less
financial burden as a viable kind of
path forward for the United States in in
alternatives to long costly wars like
Afghanistan and Iraq there is no mado
doctrine I there's this really really
smart guy national security reporter
this young this guy who I think it was
like my kid buddy
he's like a punk rocker
Spencer Spencer acrimony rights for
wired.com rights for Dangermond I didn't
I didn't interview with him about the
book and when she was super harsh on the
book it was this really confrontational
interview which is exactly what I
expected from him it's why I love him
but he was like what I'm surprised by is
there's no mado doctrine of how we
should go to war and how we should get
out of war and boy howdy do am I not
qualified to do that
to be that I I think that it is worth
really in a non ad hominem in a
substantive non partisan way engaging
with what is essentially Barack Obama's
way of waging war in the world and he is
a multilateral list for some things he
is happy to wage secret war in a greatly
expanded way all over the world in a way
that he doesn't have have to answer for
because it's secret that's the beauty of
it for politicians but when it comes to
interventions that are not secret that
are overt he is absolutely a
multilateral list and that was typify by
what happened in Libya and that is a
form of American that is a form of
exerting American power using the fact
that we have a military that we spend as
much money on as the rest of the world's
military's combined to advance
international interest in foster
international cooperation on national
security matters we would not have gone
to Libya had the Arab League not said go
to Libya and so and similarly with the
Arab League not saying with the air with
the Arab League in a very different
situation on Syria I think that's part
of the reason that they've taken a very
different approach to Syria so you are
constrained by the fact that you are
checking in with everybody else who you
see as being on the same side of you on
an issue you can in a sense intervene
less on the other hand maybe you can
intervene more because if you've got an
international coalition
everything looks everything looks legit
it's much more George HW Bush than it is
any other modern president so I don't I
mean I think that's I think that's
Obama's way I don't know that I'm
qualified to weigh in on whether it's
right or wrong but it's a very very
different approach than what for example
Mitt Romney is offering thank you okay
in the middle go ahead
first of all I'd like to thank you
Rachel for everything you do I think if
there were more Rachel madhouse the
country would be a lot better off
that's very nice to me to say if there
are no more Rachel Meadows and and
secondly I've got a quick comment and a
question
can you just keep it to the question cuz
we need to end in a few minutes so brief
question I'd like to say that I was
drafted in 1968 okay
I found an extremely valuable thing to
happen in my life I also found that my
family and all my friends became
extremely interested in the outcome of
the Vietnam War the day I was drafted
the question I have is money is behind
war and I want you please to say
something about the corrosive influence
of money and our campaigns President
Obama I'm told needs a billion dollars
for every election what's wrong with
this picture thank you thank you
and this year do we feel any differently
about the idea that however many
hundreds of billions of dollars are
going to be spent on each side that some
hundreds of those billions will be spent
by money that we can trace to nowhere in
the front page of the Boston Globe today
is about how the likely nominee on the
Republican side the super PAC that is
supporting him is distinguished by the
fact that a lot of the donations to that
PAC are listed as organizations as
corporate shells and so even when people
are willing to even when people are
forced by the few elections rules we've
got left to disclose something about
where a donation comes from if you put
it through a corporate shell there's no
way to trace it back to a human I always
wonder if that means there's no way to
trace it back to a country either like
if China had a real preference between
Barack Obama and Mitt Romney do we
really think that they wouldn't figure
out a way to I don't know that would be
against the rules they say yeah if the
FEC was in charge of enforcing state
limits every American Road would be an
Autobahn
the corrosive power of money is as old
as politics itself but we have gone
through in the series of four or five
Supreme Court decisions that have gutted
what was what what remained of American
election law we are now in a Wild West
period where not only are we looking at
mysterious funders in on a massive scale
like we have never seen before I mean
one person could write a 1 billion
dollar check and to fund somebody's
campaign right and if we're amazed by
Pro fact that Barack Obama needs to
raise a billion dollars and they'll
raise a billion dollars on the other
side what about the fact that somebody
who wanted I don't know this year's
Steve Forbes or this year's Ross Perot
or this year's I don't know Eric Prince
or somebody to be competitive why not
find one of America's billionaires say
you're one of these guys who's worth
seven or eight billion dollars writes a
1 billion dollar check okay now it's
three-way race not by virtue of any
campaign but purely by the interest of
one billionaires interests didn't use to
yeah we've always worried about money in
politics we never worried about it like
this so I think that we are in a
position right now that's a very very
hard opportunity in vironment for
political reform because these the
corrosion here mostly came through
Supreme Court decisions and you don't
appeal Supreme Court decisions what
you're talking about in order to fix
this I think and I don't say this
lightly is probably an amendment to the
American Constitution and that's a
really big undertaking so you know I
think we are a long way off from fixing
it and as they continue to strike down
state efforts to even regulate it at the
state level it's going to be hard to
even set a good example around the
country for how the for something that
the nation might want to emulate it's
the thing that worries me the most in
all of politics
okay okay we keep adding questions to
more brief brief questions do you have a
question okay go ahead
breathe to what extent has the US
government changed its concept of what
constitutes a threat and you go further
back in your book than the global war on
terrorism but in in announcing this the
Bush administration effectively waged
war on a type of war on a tactic
propagated by you know scattered covert
enemy and so I guess my question is to
what extent has the unmooring of the
locust of a sustained military threat
actually further enabled the unmooring
of the military itself it's I see it
more as a symptom than a cause I think I
mean what wall I should say I mean
remember it was the war on terrorism and
then it became the war on terror so we
went from it being a war on a tactic to
being the war on a bad feeling all right
which was can you get any more war on
you like so it was but by that the
vagueness of the of what we were having
a war on should have been assigned to us
that there was something wrong
and I think was a sign that there was
something wrong I think people are
creeped out that we have a Department of
Homeland Security since when does
America have a homeland I mean that's
right it's creepy it's a creepy word
like we don't think of ourselves that
way the same idea of a war on terror
seems like a deliberately vague thing
designed to encompass all sorts of
things that wouldn't otherwise be
justified if you didn't call them more
but when you don't have to win the
argument your argument can suck when you
don't have to engage in a rigorous
debate that if you lose that debate you
will not get your way your arguments can
be flabby and you can point at I mean
the way that the way I write about the I
won't go back into the founder stuff but
you you can identify anything as being
worthy of this war moniker that you give
it which can justify massive
international expense so I I think that
when a president can decide alone what
is that we are
aging war on when there is no price tag
put on it remember that I mean although
the post 9/11 war funding was not
factored into the budget it was all
emergency supplementals like oh look
every six months oh the worst alarm Wow
the worst line woah it's like a fish
going around a goldfish bowl look a
castle look a castle look it's like it's
not it's the when when you do not have
to explain yourself to the public
because it's secret when you do not have
to win the debate in Congress because
the debate doesn't happen in Congress
when you do not have to justify the
funding because nobody knows how much
it's costing your arguments can be
incredibly vague and you can call
anything worthy of war you can pick out
a transnational terrorist organization
you can pick a country that has no
connection to terrorism and say that it
does when you don't have to have good
debates you don't have to have good
arguments and that's why I want to snap
good debates thank you I wrote you I
think you used to be a customer of mine
when you were at Lincoln Dillons at the
end of Broad Street was my shot for the
whole time you were there
Wow two questions you guys don't know
what I was like them used to Louis 9
Pittman were you a customer yes did you
like me used to go in the turf Tavern at
lunchtime yes thank you very much
exposed as a daytime drinker in my last
question thank you thank you so much
Rachel Maddow thank you
[Applause]